AND MOST PEOPLE RECOVER.
BILL HEMMER, THANK YOU FOR THAT
UP-TO-DATE INFORMATION.
THERE IS SO MUCH DISINFORMATION
GOING AT THIS MOMENT ON YOUR
TEXT, WE CERTAINLY ARE.
WE HAVEN’T FACED A MEDICAL
CRISIS LIKE THIS IN LIVING
MEMORY.
WE KNOW CORONAVIRUS CONSTITUTES
A MAJOR THREAT TO THE COUNTRY,
BUT WHAT WE REALLY DON’T HAVE A
CLEAR PICTURE OF RIGHT NOW IS
WHAT’S COMING NEXT.
WE SPENT THE WEEKEND TALKING TO
SOME OF THE SMARTEST PEOPLE WE
KNOW IN MEDICINE, IN BUSINESS,
AND IN POLITICS.
EVERYONE HAD STRONG OPINIONS
NEEDLESS TO SAY BUT WHAT WAS
STRIKING WAS THERE WAS NO CLEAR
CONSENSUS ON HOW THE COUNTRY
SHOULD RESPOND TO THIS.
ALL DECENT INFORMED PEOPLE BUT
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT POINTS OF
VIEW.
THAT SHOULD NOT SURPRISE YOU.
PEOPLE OF GOOD FAITH ARE WORKING
TOWARD A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT
GOALS TONIGHT WHICH AT TIMES
COLLIDE WITH ONE ANOTHER.
A FIRST OBLIGATION EVERYONE
AGREES IS TO KEEP OUR PEOPLE
SAFE.
WE CAN PREVENT AMERICANS FROM
GETTING THE CORONAVIRUS, WE
SHOULD DO THAT.
AT THE SAME TIME, WE NEED TO UP
PROTECT OUR ECONOMY AND IT IS
NOT JUST SOMETHING THAT
WALL STREET CARES ABOUT TO BE
TOTALLY CLEAR.
ECONOMIC DECLINE FOR EVERYONE
ESPECIALLY AT THE BOTTOM OF THE
ECONOMY.
IT’S A LEGITIMATE HUMAN CONCERN,
NOT JUST FINANCIAL, IT’S ABOUT
FAMILIES.
HERE IS THE PROBLEM, WE HAVE TWO
IMPERATIVES AND THEY OFTEN
CONFLICT SO IF YOU ASK AN
EPIDEMIOLOGIST WHAT WE OUGHT TO
DO NEXT, THE ANSWER IS SIMPLE,
SHUT IT DOWN, CLOSE EVERY PUBLIC
SPACE UNTIL THE VIRUS PASSES.
HOSPITALS WOULD GET A PASS, OF
COURSE BUT RESTAURANTS AND BARS,
HOTELS, MOVIE THEATERS,
AIRLINES, EVERYTHING.
FROM A PUBLIC HEALTH STANDPOINT,
THAT MAKES SENSE BUT WHAT WOULD
BE THE CONSEQUENCES OF DOING
THAT?
’S MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE WOULD LOSE THEIR JOBS,
SOME OF THEM FOR GOOD.
WE WOULD ENTER A SEVERE
RECESSION WITH MASS UNEMPLOYMENT
AND IT COULD GET WORSE FROM
THERE.
IT’S NOT A JOKE, THAT COULD
HAPPEN.
WOULD SEE AN AWFUL LOT OF PEOPLE
IN POVERTY IN MIDDLE AMERICA AND
THAT POSES ITS OWN KIND OF
PUBLIC HEALTH RISK.
FOUR COUNTRIES ARE NEVER HEALTHY
COUNTRIES.
YOU WANT GREAT HEALTH CARE,
YOU’VE GOT TO PAY FOR IT AND YOU
HAVE TO HAVE MONEY TO DO SO.
YOU SEE THE PROBLEM, RESPONDING
TO THIS EPIDEMIC REQUIRES
BALANCE.
IS A COMPLEX QUESTION AND THE
DEEPER INTO WHAT YOU DIG THE
MORE CONVINCED OF THAT YOU WILL
BECOME.
THE ANSWERS ARE NOT OBVIOUS.
DON’T LET ANYONE LIE TO YOU
ABOUT THAT AND OF COURSE THEY
ARE.
YOU’LL HEAR PEOPLE SAY THEY HAVE
A SIMPLE ANSWER THAT WILL FIX
EVERYTHING.
ONLY FOOLS PRETEND THEY CAN SEE
THE FUTURE.
WISE PEOPLE ADMIT UNCERTAINTY.
THAT IS THE HALLMARK OF WISDOM.
TONIGHT, HERE’S WHAT WE DO KNOW.
FIRST, WE ARE ONLY AT THE
BEGINNING OF ALL OF THIS WE ARE
PRETTY CERTAIN OF THAT.
DR. ANTHONY KATHERINE JOHNSON
SAID AS MUCH OVER THE WEEKEND.
>> AS I’VE SAID MANY TIMES AND I
WILL REPEAT IT, THE WORST IS YET
AHEAD FOR US.
IT IS HOW WE RESPOND TO THAT
CHALLENGE THAT IS GOING TO
DETERMINE WHAT THE ULTIMATE
END POINT IS GOING TO BE.
>> Tucker: SHUTDOWNS AND
TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS WHICH ARE
INCREASINGLY IN PLACE WILL HELP
SLOW THE SPREAD BUT THEY ARE NOT
ENOUGH, NOT A BIG ENOUGH
RESPONSE FOR WHAT’S COMING.
THE NEW YORK
GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO MUSTERING
THE MILITARY TO FIGHT THE VIRUS.
>> THE COMING CRISIS IS
OVERWHELMING OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM.
THAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
NET CURVE IS A WAVE AND IT’S
GOING TO BREAK ON THE HOSPITAL
SYSTEM.
WE NEED ADDITIONAL BEDS AND WE
NEED FROM THE ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS TO COME IN HERE AND
RETROFIT STATE BUILDINGS,
DORMITORIES, ET CETERA, START
NOW.
BRING IN THAT ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS.
THIS IS WHAT THEY DO, THEY BUILD
BUILD.
>> Tucker: AT A PRESS
CONFERENCE TODAY, SAID THE
ADMINISTRATION IS STRONGLY
CONSIDERING HIS REQUEST AND OF
COURSE, OTHERWISE WE COULD USE
THE MILITARY’S EXPERTISE AND
MANPOWER.
THINGS GET BAD WE WILL NEED MORE
VENTILATORS THAN WE CURRENTLY
HAVE.
WE MAY NEED MORE BREATHING MASKS
TOO APPEARED IN ITALY, THE
MILITARY HAS BEEN MOBILIZED IN
AN EFFORT TO QUADRUPLE
PRODUCTION AND THE VENTILATOR
MANUFACTURER.
IN SOUTH KOREA, THE MILITARY
ASSISTING IN MASS PRODUCTION.
WE HAVE THE MOST SOPHISTICATED
ARMED FORCES ON EARTH AND THE
BEST FUNDED, NO DOUBT MANY OTHER
WAYS I CAN HELP, THEY HELP SO
MANY OTHER NATIONS IN CRISIS AND
THEY WANT TO, THEY ARE AMERICAN.
AND THEN THERE IS OUR SECOND
PRIORITY, KEEPING OUR ECONOMY
STABLE.
ONCE AGAIN, THIS IS NOT THE SAME
AS USING MONETARY POLICY TO PROP
UP THE STOCK MARKET.
WASHINGTON HAS BECOME CONVINCED
THE FEDERAL RESERVE IS THE ONLY
AVAILABLE INSTRUMENT FOR
MANAGING OUR ECONOMY.
IS NOT ONLY UNIMAGINATIVE AND
SMALL MINDED, IT IS DANGEROUS.
HOW MUCH CHEAP MONEY CAN WE
PRINT BEFORE THE PUBLIC LOSES
FAITH IN THE SYSTEM AND
INFLATION EXPLODES?
ECONOMIST FROM WASHINGTON SEEM
TO THINK THAT WILL NEVER HAPPEN.
WE CAN DO THIS FOREVER, BUT WE
CAN’T AND THEY KNOW WE CAN’T ON
SOME LEVEL.
AT SOME POINT, WE WILL BECOME
ZIMBABWE AND YOU DON’T WANT
THAT.
IT’S MISSING THE POINT ANYWAY.
THE REAL IMPERATIVE IS SAVING
JOBS.
FOR GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRATS AND
ADMINISTRATORS AND CORPORATE HR
DIRECTORS, A MONTH OUT OF THE
OFFICE CONSTITUTES A VACATION
BUT FOR THE CLASSES BELOW, IT
COULD BE THE BEGINNING OF A LONG
SPIRAL, A REAL ONE.
OF WAITERS, BARTENDERS, RETAIL
WORKERS, HUGE PARTS OF THE
SERVICE INDUSTRY ON WHICH WE ARE
DEPENDENT COULD SEE THEIR INCOME
DROPPED TO ZERO AND NOT COME
BACK.
THE FORMER CHAIRMAN OF THE
PRESIDENT’S COUNCIL OF ECONOMIC
ADVISORS JUST WARNED THAT A
MILLION JOBS COULD VANISH IN THE
MONTH OF APRIL, A MILLION PEOPLE
SUDDENLY WITHOUT JOBS.
THAT IS THE NIGHTMARE SCENARIO.
MORE OMINOUS THEY ARE UNSTABLE
COUNTRIES ALWAYS.
YOU DON’T WANT THAT.
SOME OF THE PROFESSIONAL CLASS
HAS SUGGESTED A GUARANTEED BASIC
INCOME AS A RESPONSE TO THIS
THREAT.
BUT ROMNEY HAS SUGGESTED SENDING
EVERY AMERICAN A MONTHLY CHECK
FOR $1,000.
IS LIKELY A WELL MEANING IDEA
BUT IT IS ALSO DECADENT AND
FOOLISH.
NAME A PLACE THAT’S BECOME
HAPPIER AND MORE PROSPEROUS
UNDER A SCHEME LIKE THAT.
THE INNER-CITY, RURAL AREAS WERE
HALF THE MALE POPULATION GETS
MONTHLY DISABILITY CHECKS OR FOR
THAT MATTER IF WE ARE BEING
HONEST, HOW MANY HAPPILY IDLE
INHERITED MONEY PEOPLE DO YOU
KNOW, RICH PEOPLE?
NONE, THEY ARE ALL DRUNK.
OF COURSE THEY ARE.
PEOPLE NEED TO WORK, THEY WANT
TO WORK, WORK GIVES THE MEANING
AND PURPOSE AND DIGNITY.
IS NOT SOME HOLLOW SLOGAN, IT IS
TRUE.
HAPPILY, THERE IS A MODEL IN
PROGRESS FOR HOW WE CAN SAVE
WORK UNDERWAY NOW IN GERMANY.
THE GERMAN GOVERNMENT RUNS A
PROGRAM THAT MEANS SHORT TIME.
EMPLOYERS ARE ENCOURAGED NOT TO
LAY OFF THEIR WORKERS BUT
INSTEAD PLACED THEM ON REDUCED
HOURS.
THE THEN STEPS IN TO CALM DOWN
NOT CONFISCATE THOSE WAGERS TO
HELP WITH PAYROLL.
MAY COST TAXPAYERS MORE THAN THE
GRAND MONTH PROGRAM BUT
CRITICALLY, IT KEEPS PEOPLE IN
THEIR JOBS.
IT’S ALSO STRAIGHTFORWARD UNLIKE
SO MANY OF THE DOUBLE SECRET
THAT FOR A TAX REBATE PROGRAMS
THAT GENIUSES IN CONGRESS ALWAYS
COME UP WITH AND TELLING YOU
SHOULD LOVE AND BE HAPPY WITH
THEY DON’T UNDERSTAND AND
NEITHER DO THEY.
THIS IDEA HAS A CLEAR GOAL AND
IT ACHIEVES IT.
DURING THE 2008 FINANCIAL
CRISIS, GERMANY’S ECONOMY SHRANK
BY A HIGHER PROPORTION THAN OURS
DID IN AMERICA.
AT THE SAME TIME, GERMANY’S
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE ACTUALLY FELL.
LABOR FORCE PARTICIPATION ROSE,
SO AMAZINGLY IN THE MIDDLE OF AN
ECONOMIC CONTRACTION, A BAD
RECESSION, MORE PEOPLE WERE
WORKING THAN BEFORE.
THAT’S THE KEY AS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO TURBULENT TIMES.
EMPLOYMENT, STABILITY,
MEANINGFUL WORK.
YOU WANT TO HELP PEOPLE WHETHER